[Applaudissements]
tu papa de benjamin évidemment jean
pierre cassart est ingénieur midam juste
anecdotes ont avalé des césars ensemble
aux divers invités aux césar pour
diffuser cette interview aux césars
triomphe exceptionnel et il ya beaucoup
de producteurs qui sont allés voir le
papa de benjamin et ont proposé de jouer
dans last rx et moi je mets le pauvre à
faire regarder je pouvais parler pendant
six coups ou vous allez en vacances le
canal est d'accord je vous explique
peut-être on vous l'a dit on l'a
peut-être pas dit ce temps là je suis là
je fais pas être content par des visages
arrivés ici vous voudrez serré et à tout
ce que j'ai tourné pendant 20 ans et
vous tout ce que vous dites c'est vrai
ce qu'est la balle est requis pour rien
ou clans lisez votre cv j'ai adoré un
mec qui me fait plus chier maintenant et
je ne comprends même pas qu'on vous en
gaz pour faire des interviews vous savez
même pas ce que c'est qu'un acteur
sichem ans j'ai une cousine qui est je
m'en fous de votre coup j'ai une coco
écouter en vendée à la suite de votre
cousine
l'attentât il dit
jusqu'à quand même 10 mai dès 10 ans de
moins je pense que rafael repartez les
pieds de ben non c'est vrai à bruxelles
chez simplement je suis aussi avec crise
avec collombert oui